now to Washington D.C in the fight over
raising the federal debt ceiling AKA
preventing a government default that's
going to enter a critical new phase
today with the return of Congress the
White House and the Republican leaders
spent the holiday weekend working out
the details of a deal but now they've
got to try to sell that deal to
reluctant lawmakers in their own parties
the agreement will get its first
significant test in the house this
afternoon and Nicole Killian is on
Capitol Hill for us Nicole let's just
say not everybody is cheering good
morning
hey good morning to you Tony this deal
is going to need bipartisan backing to
get through house Republican leaders
insists they have strong support but not
all of their members say they're going
to vote for it and some Democrats aren't
on board either
today the house cut its Memorial Day
recess short to return to Washington
after President Biden and speaker Kevin
McCarthy reached an agreement on a plan
to raise the nation's debt limit I never
say I'm confident with the Congress
review but I feel very good about it so
it's not a hundred percent of what
everybody wants but when you look the
country is going to be stronger the
proposed legislation dubbed the fiscal
responsibility act would raise the debt
ceiling through early 2025 enabling the
U.S to keep borrowing money to pay its
bills in exchange federal spending would
be limited including funding cuts to
unused coveted relief and the IRS and
stricter work requirements for those on
food assistance programs like Snap
compromise means sacrifice for the most
marginalized and the most vulnerable we
are not seeing our Ultra Rich our
corporations make any sacrifices at all
but it's not just some Progressive
Democrats who are bulking at the deal so
were many conservative Republicans that
there's people across the blood Spectrum
they're opposed to this several
hardliners are threatening to Scuttle
the bill which faces its first test this
afternoon when it comes up for a vote in
the gop-dominated rules committee Texas
is Chip Roy sits on the panel and is a
firm no so I'm going to be making that
loud and clear to my Republican
colleagues that this is not a deal that
we should be taking
if the bill clears the rules committee
the Full House would vote on the debt
deal Wednesday the White House has
called more than 60 house Democrats and
continues to work the phones to try to
get them on board Nate
Nicole thank you